I just realized I did not plan a witty
opening be funny this movie was called I
am number two a realistic plan openings
so I'm number four is about a group of
nine aliens who are residing on earth in
secret hiding away from another group of
aliens who are at war with them from
their planet so our stories about the
fourth one he's hiding away on earth and
trying to live a normal high school life
is just a guy but he has these crazy
alien powers but at the same time he's
kind of in the middle of alien puberty
he's just sort of discovering all these
powers that he has he doesn't know how
to control it and yes like runs the
janitor's closet except it alone I'm
just an alias so Timothy Olyphant plays
his protector he's assigned to always
guard him on this planet because these
warring aliens are always on the lookout
to find one of these nine to kill him
and of course he meets a girl so I was
like I like Earth I want to stay here
but these aliens are after him and so
it's kind of dangerous but he loves this
girl and so that's where I'm really a
dork so this film was directed by DJ
Caruso he directed disturbia and Eagle
Eye I really like Disturbia ego I wasn't
too big on although it was entertaining
I got actually say this is actually my
favorite of those three I just want to
get the greatest reviews and watching
the movie I was like why I don't really
understand it's it's produced by Michael
Bay and I honestly really prefer him as
a producer of a director because all of
his films always have great production
values they always look really great in
everything and so he's really really
good at producing the DJ Caruso actually
does a really nice job with the action
here because so much of the action we've
seen lately in Hollywood is so shaky and
up-close you have no idea what the heck
is going on this film thumbs action very
well you know big wide shots of things
happening
of intense stuff the action in this film
I was actually completely exhilarated by
like I really really liked it believe it
or not I actually found myself
completely wrapped up in this guy's
story I was so surprised I've started
this movie thinking I really hope this
is all right and then as it started and
progressed I kept trying to figure out
what the big deal was with what's the
problem but no I really enjoyed it
I from beginning to end I completely
enjoyed this movie now the middle
section of the movie doesn't have too
much action so it's really kind of you
have to get engrossed in the story that
he kind of meets this girl and they're
sort of getting to know each other and
you had to be into that story otherwise
you're not going to like the movie at
all and I really found it entertaining I
just got a text that's actually
hilarious
I hope you've seen Scott Pilgrim so I
was really into the story the romance
part of the story the science fiction
part of the story all the action was
really fun I really really liked how
these guys had these powers and
everything obviously this film is really
keen to something that's very popular
lately among teens and that is the
romance with the creatures and the
monsters over there but this film I
think actually does it well it actually
bounces the whole you know the whole
paranormal crap and then the romance
stuff the main character is played by
Alex Pettyfer and I thought he did a
really good job I his performance was
really good Timothy Olyphant was fun the
girl who plays the character of Sarah
the girl that he kind of likes she did
fine too I liked how she was in a
photography cuz I like photography and
everything it was just it I liked this
movie I was completely surprised I don't
see what the big deal is critics have
something up their brother some of the
problems I had with it where the villain
seemed pretty underdeveloped I mean it
was just kind of like this race that you
were supposed to be afraid of like you
didn't really know until near the end
really why they were actually warring
and stuff and it was just sort of like
they needed to add villains so let's
create some nasty race of aliens it was
just the villains were underdeveloped if
you're not into the story it can seem
really corny like really Tina SHhhh you
know I mean I liked it I'm sorry I I'm
kind of a dork
so item number 4 is a fun movie if you
can just kind of suspend yourself
disbelief you know to spend suspend your
disbelief my gosh it's actually a fun
movie I really really have fun with it
and I'm going to give it three out of
four stars actually liked it a little
more than unknown what do you know I
wasn't even going to
see this moving I decided to on a whim
so hey see unknowns yeah I'm number four
I like them both haha
I drink some Mountain Dew can you tell